[Applause]
a powder keg of anger frustration and
helplessness among sri lankans
there's been months of discontent over
an economy close to bankruptcy
people have been demanding the president
the prime minister and the government
resign blaming them for mismanagement
and corruption
premium
has now bowed to pressure
as a leader who always listen to the
people i'm asking you
what do we do now
[Music]
we want mahinda
[Applause]
we want mahinda
that means i do not need to
bust in resign around the country a
pro-government crowd confronted
protesters in colombo who have spent
weeks calling for change
some were injured while tents and
posters were torn up
some say the police did not act fast
enough to stop them
but shortly after protesters regrouped
and launched a counter-attack targeting
the buses that transported them
even destroying luxury vehicles and
houses belonging to rajapaksa loyalists
the government imposed a countrywide
curfew until wednesday morning and
deployed the military to disperse the
crowds
it had the opposite effect
large crowds gathered opposite the
president's office vowing not to be
intimidated
president gotaby's move to sacrifice his
brother doesn't seem to be working
today's resignation is long overdue
but is unlikely to address the cause the
demands of the protesters so even
despite the curfew and a state of
emergency many are on the roads now
because they feel their calls their
demands need to be heard
live ammunition was fired when
protesters broke down gates to the
premier's residence the president had
invoked a state of emergency on friday
for the past 30 days protesters have
maintained a largely peaceful campaign
demanding the rajapaksa brothers and
their government resign but protesters
say the violence unleashed by the prime
minister's supporters forced them to
respond police and the armed forces have
the challenge of now restoring calm
miner fernandez al jazeera colombo